I would now like to calculate the moment
of inertia for a very thin disc so we
have a thin disc and the radius of that
disc is R and it has a mass m and I
would like to calculate the moment of
inertia for this disc now let's just
remind what point we're calculating it
about about the center of mass so our
definition of moment of inertia was take
a small element mass element of the disc
in fact we're gonna see it doesn't have
to be small take a mass element of the
disc that's useful and multiplied by the
perpendicular distance squared from the
point we're calculating it so the way
I'll do it is I will choose a ring now
I'm going to choose a ring of radius R
and now I'll make the ring of certain
thickness and this thickness is d R now
in this calculation we're going to take
a limit as dr goes to 0 so even though
the ring has some finite thickness its
radius will eventually treat it as all
of the mass element a distance R from
the center so R will be our integration
variable and that will be equal to R cm
what we're calling our cm in or abstract
result now the DM is the tricky part
so what is the mass that's contained in
this area disc of radius R and thickness
dr well one way to think about that is
it's here we didn't say this but our
thin disc is going to be a uniform and
so we can describe the uniform mass per
unit area as the total mass divided by
the area of the whole disc and then we
can say that the mass in that air in
that ring is equal to Sigma mass per
area times the area of the outer ring
- the area of the inner ring now when we
expand this out DM em over PI R squared
we get PI R squared + 2 RDR + D our
quantity squared minus PI R squared and
you can see those terms cancel and so
what I get is M times PI R squared and
in here I have 2 pi r dr now this is
only order dr + a second term that goes
like pi dr squared and so when i take
this limit as dr goes to 0 this term is
much much smaller than that term and so
i can say my mass element is n pi r
squared times 2 pi r dr now let's think
about this term why it makes sense when
we're shrinking our ring so taking the
limit as dr goes to 0 and the ring just
becomes extremely thin ring at radius R
then this piece is a circumference and
this piece is just the width and so it's
no surprise that area is 2 PI R times d
pi r dr in the limit and now that
enables us to write the moment of
inertia about the center of mass I see
em let's pull out these constants M PI R
squared
now we're integrating over the body
let's hold off on the limits for the
moment and put our values for DM that's
a 2 pi r dr and we have our distance
squared which was again the radius R
squared and so the tube the PI's will
cancel I have 2 M over R squared times
the integral of r cubed dr now we're
supposedly integrating over the body but
what does that body integral actually
mean
well what we're doing is we're taking a
series of rings and adding them up as we
go from a very from the origin out to
the radius of the whole disk so the
limits of our body integral with respect
to our integration variable we start
with rings that are essentially have no
width and we're integrating these were
adding up the contribution of every ring
until we get two rings of radius R and
our integration variable R cubed dr now
this is an integral that's easy to do
that's R to the fourth over four between
0 and R equals R and when we put that in
the two cancels the four and oh the PI
we lost so let's make sure this pi
should be an M so we have the 2 over the
4 is 1/2 M R squared and that is the
moment of inertia of a disc about an
axis passing through the center
perpendicular to the plane of the disc